well they're basically up in the ante
because it's not just um obviously
either liz truss or boris johnson who
are being singled out here we just saw
uh emmanuel macron front spend hours in
the presence of vladimir putin uh trying
also to talk to him and getting you know
a similar sort of treatment perhaps a
little bit more polite but uh
nonetheless um also uh being
contradicted quite openly afterwards i
think what we're seeing is that the
russians are as i said here upping the
ante uh still continuing to escalate and
keep the pressure on because they don't
really have yet every piece in place uh
for um what they're threatening um in
terms of a full-scale invasion of
ukraine most of the military analysts
are looking at this anticipate that
there is you know period uh still ahead
of us of a couple of weeks out to
february 20th which is coincidentally of
course the end of the beijing olympics
but also is the declared end of the
exercises the russians are conducting in
belarus and elsewhere around ukraine's
periphery and it's then that they are
you know basically uh suggesting that
the russians will have all that it takes
to launch an invasion if they so choose
so what putin is doing is hedging he
doesn't want the pressure off he doesn't
want to to basically be seen to concede
this space in any way with all of the
various visits he's basically seeing
what we've got to offer so when he's
saying you're not listening and you're
not hearing it's because we are not
responding to what are some pretty blunt
demands that the russians have already
put forward at the um december of last
year towards the middle point of
december 17th in these written demands
and that they have verbally reinforced
ever since so right now putin doesn't
want to as i said give give way in any
way to the diplomatic effort so what do
you think you co-authored a book mr
putin operative in the kremlin so i mean
you know what is he trying to achieve
with all this
well he's trying to achieve maximum
pressure maximum tension keeping us all
on ten talks and keeping us all guessing
at what he's doing um and we are you
know of course behaving as we normally
do which we're being very open and
transparent our debates about what we
should do how we should coordinate all
out there in the open and the russians
are watching this very carefully and
hedging he's trying to figure out right
now what the cost is going to be of an
invasion and whether he can get what he
wants by some other way
so you know for this uh he really does
need to make us feel as uncomfortable as
possible i think the biggest risk for us
besides the full skill in invasion and
what this would uh obviously entail in
europe and globally i mean the
reverberations would be international
but is the risk that he tries to keep it
this pressure for um a much longer
period of time we're all looking at this
magical date of after february 20th
which is probably what he wants us to be
looking at but he could keep us in this
state of suspended animation for some
period because he thinks we're going to
crack
so what we need to keep unified and keep
up our own pressure yeah but i mean but
if he
invades ukraine he's not going to get
what he seems to want which is this much
broader
police security policy much broader
guarantees for russia i mean if he
invades that's not going to to happen is
it so
um it does seem as if he's
on some sort of mission to
divide the west at the moment
i think that's absolutely right that's
exactly what he's trying to do right now
uh trying to humiliate us insult people
uh he's trying to pick um countries off
and pit them against each other and
again we have to make sure that we uh
completely have a unified response here
and are also on the same page of
messaging what he's also testing with
this you know kind of period of
dignitaries coming to moscow is how much
uh daylight there is between them are
the messages different can he discern
any kind of cracks i mean i'm sorry that
you know to say it but the way that he's
treating liz trust is just you know an
emblematic or a way of lavrov often
these statements about you know you're
not listening is clear pure misogyny i
mean they know they're targeting her as
a woman you know they're kind of this is
a classic uh ploy on the behalf of the
russians i mean i've certainly heard
them and seen them do this before but
it's you know this insult to see if they
can get our backs up and to see if we
can get some kind of response playing to
what they see as weaknesses and
vulnerabilities trying to pick the uk
off from the rest of europe you know try
to see if they can inflame some of the
tensions because of brexit so we have to
be on guard against all of these kinds
of behaviors and actions yeah i mean i'm
very interested what you say because we
had lord darrick on the program uh the
former ambassador to the u.s just
he said too that it was a very typical
um way of the russians to deal with
someone new in the foreign secretary's
job you go further and you say it is
outright misogyny do you
yes i do i mean look what they did to
angela merkel when she first became
chancellor of germany i mean this is a
classic story about one of her first
meetings with putin in um his uh dutcher
he knows that she's scared of dogs and
allows his uh black labrador to
basically come and sniff around her feet
i mean i haven't seen him try that with
any of the male uh leaders you know he
tries to go in for a vulnerability
assumes that women might be thrown off
their game a lot more there's of course
a lot more women in uh european politics
and i mean good luck looking for the
women in russian politics i mean there
are a few you know the foreign uh
spokesperson a central bank for example
but you know he tries to take advantage
of anything that he thinks might be seen
as a weakness to show people up
i mean on the american front is joe
biden do you think doing enough
to deter putin and i guess
in the end it is that's what putin wants
isn't it another summit maybe with with
joe biden some way down the line
well he's hinting at that and
being very obvious you know they're even
saying to you know the brits the french
and you know we have chancellor schultz
of germany heading out there soon you
know while he said the same to them look
we don't want to talk to you we want to
talk to the americans i mean they've
made that clear at different points
because they want to put the americans
in uh the difficult position of
negotiating over the heads of everyone
ukraine and europe as well to again
stoke divisions so i do think that what
president biden his team and everybody
else i mean i just think there's a lot
of kudos right now to everyone uh
european leaders uk
for coordinating and to try to keep our
message and close consultation we've got
to keep at it because again we have to
recognize that the russians want to pit
is against each other because they want
to see what they can get out of all of
us and if there comes to be a split
about how to react and then there may be
you know pressure that we impose on each
other to uh basically come up with some
kind of compromise that be might be more
to russia's liking and again we must not
rule out in any way even on the things
that i've said that they will invade
ukraine because you know putin will
eventually have the wherewithal to do
that
at some point in the next couple of
weeks yeah and i mean you served as i
just mentioned earlier in
in the trump administration um
how do you think he would be dealing
with this he had a
well i suppose a sort of interesting as
a way of putting it interesting
relationship with putin
well it was very much a personalized um
relationship and we have to avoid that
at this particular point because this is
about you know russia and ukraine about
european security and you know the
actions of the russian state and the
kremlin you know against the sovereign
independent neighboring state which
again will have global reverberations so
doing it purely personally back channels
and you know backslapping uh kind of
behind the door agreements is not going
to be
a method for success i mean that's
exactly what putin wanted was this idea
of a personalized relationship and
unfortunately president trump played
right into it and also he also played
into it by the constant rifts and
fighting uh with european allies over a
whole variety of other issues uh putin
is most deterred or let's just say he'll
recalculate if he sees uh unity and
basically a very strong resilient
response on the part of europe and the
united states okay very interesting
fiona hill appreciate your time thank
you very much
thank you